how's it going everybody it's Warren and
yesterday at CinemaCon Disney showed new
footage for Avengers in game and luckily
for us we have reports on what was shown
we have the description of the scenes
that were shown and the dialogue from
the scenes I'll break it all down in
this video if you're worried about
spoilers don't worry too much if you've
seen all the trailers and the Avengers
in-game special look you've basically
seen what is happening in this scene
there's just a few extended moments and
some new dialogue so it's not too
spoilery but if you're trying to avoid
everything about Avengers in game before
it comes out here's your warning also
I'm still doing my Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway along with a Thanos art piece
if you'd like to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain okay so the scene that they
showed at CinemaCon was very similar to
the one that they showed at the Disney
shareholders meeting but again there are
some extra moments and some new dialogue
the footage begins with Captain Marvel
vowing to take down Thanos herself but
the Avengers are adamant that she
doesn't go alone and they fight as a
team
Captain America says that up there space
is more of Captain Marvel's territory
and maybe she knows some people that
know where Thanos is however nebula
chimes in and says there's no need I
know where Thanos is nebula said that
when she would work and train with
feyo's he would tell her about a garden
planet he intended to retreat to once
his plan was accomplished this of course
is the planet that we saw him on at the
end of Avengers infinity war rocket then
pulls out a hologram of a planet that
shows a massive energy surge he says
that it's identical to the one that
happened on earth referring to the snap
rocket says the energy surge only
happened two days ago so Thanos has
recently used the stones again so the
Avengers are able to locate where
exactly Thanos is and Captain Marvel
says they need to go fight Thanos and
use the stones to reverse the snap black
widow agrees and so does Captain America
but he says that the Avengers usually
work as a team and that they'll all go
together
however Bruce Banner is still skeptical
and he says we've gone against Thanos
before how do we know it'll end
differently this time Captain Marvel
says because before you didn't have me
rody then chimes in and says hey new
girl everybody in this room is about
that superhero life if you don't mind me
asking
where the hell were you before Captain
Marvel explains that she was defending
other planets that are not as fortunate
enough as Earth is to have people like
the Avengers this is then where we see
the scene where Thor walks up to Captain
Marvel summons Stormbreaker and says I
like this one right after Captain
America gets up and says let's go get
this son of a wait we then see Captain
America rocket Thor Captain America
Black Widow Rhodey and nebula get back
onto Benatar Iron Man ant-man and
Hawkeye are not on the ship before they
take off rocket asks everybody who here
hasn't been to space before in which
Captain America Natasha and Rhodey all
raised their hands and rocket says you
better not puke in my ship the scene
ends with the camera focusing on Captain
America's eyes as he sees the stars in
the galaxy and they fly into space so
that's it for the scene and as you can
see it's much like the one that was
shown at the Disney shareholders meeting
but the new information that this does
tell us is that the Avengers original
plan is to in fact reverse the snap
using the Infinity Gauntlet and the
Infinity stones so this doesn't fact
confirm along with the special look that
we got the other day that the Avengers
will indeed go and try to fight Thanos
in the beginning of the movie and we
also learned that Thanos has used the
Infinity Gauntlet again so it is working
so let me know what you think about this
new footage do you think that the
Avengers will initially win against
Thanos but the stones no longer work or
do you think that they're going to lose
also what do you think Fanus use the
stones for let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below again don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Avengers endgame and Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]